herzlich willkommen zufolge 200 des faz
einspruch podcast dem podcast für recht
justiz und politik heute am mittwoch den
zweiten märz 2022 heutige mikrofon
helene bobrowski politiker respondenten
in berlin und an meiner seite corinna
budras
wirtschaftskorrespondentin in berlin und
nicht mit dabei ist sind leider pia
lorenz die erkrankt ist und die ich
setzen muss und jetzt bin ich an deiner
seite helene das ist natürlich sehr
schön pia wir schicken dir von hier aus
herzliche genesungswünsche
nach köln wir haben heute eine
jubiläumsfolge eigentlich ein grund zu
feiern wie das in der vergangenheit
glaube ich bei 50 und 100 auch der 450
auch da haben wir schon mal zum glas
gegriffen damals constantin von linken
und ich aber das ehrlich gesagt verbots
ich heute dass man heute nicht
angriffskrieg in der ukraine viel leid
bei den ukrainern
schreckliche bilder und insgesamt eine
sehr bedrückende situation
deswegen genauso wenig wie karneval
stattgefunden hat werden wir heute
feiern sondern im gegenteil wir werden
berichten über das was
in der ukraine passiert aber natürlich
auch darüber wie der westen wie
deutschland darauf reagiert dieses
umfassende paket das der bundestag jetzt
beschlossen hat und was das im einzelnen
bedeutet und jetzt konkret corinna was
in unsere themen genau also wir fingen
zusammen was es seit dem russischen
angriff auf die ukraine am
24.02 ist noch nicht mal eine woche her
was ist seitdem sich getan hat die welt
ist eine ganz andere und zwar hat es
eine zeitenwende gegeben in der
deutschen sicherheitspolitik die
deutschen waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine sind eine sache das
sondervermögen in höhe von 100
milliarden
euro für die bundeswehr für die
ertüchtigung der bundeswehr ist ein
anderes thema das wir hier vertiefen
wollen dann geht es um die
flüchtlingsströme natürlich die nach
europa kommen wobei derzeit noch gar
nicht so viele da sind aber genau die
frage ist wie welchen aufenthaltsstatus
bekommen sie da schauen wir darauf wie
der europarat reagiert der nämlich
russland
suspendiert hat ja und dann gucken wir
uns das verbot für den russischen
fernsehsender rt früher russia today in
deutschland an auch da gab es sehr
verwicklungen die sogar schon die
gerichte in alarmbereitschaft
versetzen so viel kann man jetzt schon
mal sagen dann hast du ein interview
gefühlen und interview mit hendrik
kafsack unserem wirtschafts
korrespondenten in brüssel der sich mit
all diesen sanktionspaket der
vergangenen tage von eu seite
beschäftigt hat und uns erklären wird
was es genau damit auf sich hat und wie
es wirkt ja und dann haben wir noch das
gerechte unter der woche das ist nicht
zur ukraine das genau das ist ein
bisschen artfremd diesmal aber trotzdem
gerecht und wichtig das wollten wir uns
angucken aber bevor wir jetzt zu den
wirklich schweren themen kommen doch
noch ein kleiner hinweis eben auf die
tatsache dass wir jetzt schon zum
zweihundertsten mal auf sendung gehen
also ein kleines jubiläum feiern das hat
der verlag mal zum anlass genommen hier
eine kleine umfrage zu starten und einen
gewinnspielen und da wollten wir
natürlich sie liebe hörerinnen und hörer
bzw euch dazu aufrufen daran
teilzunehmen wir wollen ein bisschen
mehr wissen wie ihr diesen podcast
findet was ihr verbessern würde auch an
unserem produkt dem faz einspruch
magazin das ja viele von ihnen auch
schon kennen ja und dazu gibt es eben
eine umfrage die flankiert ist mit einem
gewinnspiel ein wer sich die zeit nimmt
da ein paar fragen für uns zu
beantworten der kann eine reise nach
berlin gewinn zu und liebe hinnehmen so
herrlich großartig wir freuen uns auch
auf die gewinner und seine mit denen
haben wir jetzt schon geplant am 13 6 am
13 juni ein live podcast hier im faz
atrium an der friedrichstraße haben wir
unser büro und wir haben ein nettes
atrium und da wollen wir mal eine live
veranstaltung machen dazu sind die
gewinner der gewinner die gewinnerin
herzlich eingeladen und danach gibt es
noch ein get together mit uns beiden wir
hoffen dass es wird auch als hauptgewinn
wahrgenommen
jetzt haben wir doch gelacht ja das darf
man schon auch aber ich warte nur kurz
sagen übrigens auch das ist noch nicht
alles weil man muss dann auch nicht
abends vor der tür stehen sondern es
gibt auch noch eine übernachtung mit
frühstück in berlin also das alles lohnt
sich doch und jetzt sage ich noch ein
letztes mal wo man diese umfrage findet
dass es nämlich auf der internetseite
www.net schrägstrich einspruch - 200 da
kann man die umfrage finden und wenn man
dann eben auch an dem gewinnspiel
teilnehmen möchte dann kann man das da
kenntlich machen und dann geht es auch
schon schnell los wir tun auch diesen
link in unsere chance
[Musik]
ok dann steigen wir direkt ein ein
kurzer rückblick auf das was in den
vergangenen tagen passiert ist
tatsächlich haben sich ja die ereignisse
überschlagen nicht nur in der ukraine wo
die russen am frühen donnerstagmorgen
einmarschiert sind von drei seiten im
zangengriff haben sie die ukraine unter
beschuss genommen auch raketenbeschuss
und sind vorgabe kommen wohl nicht ganz
so schnell voran wie sie sich das
ursprünglich gedacht haben denn die
ukraine leisten erbitterten widerstand
auch es gab jetzt kürzlich diese
videos wo tatsächlich auch ukraine sich
völlig unbewaffnet einfach nur mit
erhobenen händen aber in großer zahl
russischen militär fahrzeugen entgegen
stellen also sehr beeindruckend wo dann
experten allerdings sagen wenn die
russen zum beispiel kiew einnehmen und
des sa zum häuserkampf kommt was zu
erwarten ist weil die ukraine selbst
wenn die stadt erobert wird nicht
aufgeben werden dann ist es natürlich
ein wahnsinniges blutbad das da
angerichtet wird mit vielen vielen toten
insofern ist es einerseits finde ich
sehr
beeindruckend wie die ukraine sich den
russen entgegenstellen und andererseits
bedeutet das eben sehr sehr großes leid
ja also man muss natürlich immer wieder
ganz klar sagen auch weil es in der
politik von ganz rechts wie ganz links
immer mal wieder leute gibt die das
infragestellen die alleinige
verantwortung für all das was passiert
liegt bei russland und vor allen dingen
den staatspräsidenten wladimir putin der
offensichtlich völlig unberechenbar ist
genau ist eigentlich schon länger wie
wir alle spätestens seit 2 14 seit der
annexion der krim wissen aber es gab
eben doch noch viele insbesondere in der
spd die darauf gesetzt haben dass man
irgendwie durch eine wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und so weiter irgendwie
auf ihn einwirken könnte und immer dran
geglaubt haben das ist doch eine art von
rationalität
gibt und die nun dann am donnerstag oder
seit donnerstag alle sagen wir sind in
einer neuen welt aufgewacht wo manche
seien naja eigentlich ist die welt nicht
neu sondern wir haben jetzt nur die
augen aufgemacht
jedenfalls ist es interessant was in der
deutschen politik sich getan hat in
diesen wenigen tagen zwischen donnerstag
und sonntag wir wissen aus eigener
recherchen das am donnerstag noch und
auch am freitag in den allermeisten
ministerien und auch im kanzleramt man
davon ausging es war das ganze scharf zu
verurteilen und als völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg mit der alleinschuld von
wladimir putin deutlich zu benennen aber
eben ansonsten an wirtschaftssanktionen
zu arbeiten die die es damals ja schon
gab die ersten zwei pakete nochmal
nachzuschärfen aber das swift abkommen
wurde eigentlich zunächst von deutscher
seite ausgeschlossen dass anzugehen also
den zahlungsverkehr einzuschränken
waffenlieferungen waren kein thema und
auch ansonsten also die wurden auch
explizit noch mal ausgeschlossen wie
auch in der vergangenheit und sodann gab
es das muss am wochenende gewesen sein
also zwischen freitagabend und
sonntagmorgen überschlugen sich
offensichtlich politisch die ereignisses
wurde wild telefoniert und am
samstag gesicherte durch dass
deutschland entgegen der ursprünglichen
ankündigung eben doch unter anderem
panzerfäuste an die ukraine liefern wird
und die größte überraschung und zwar
nicht nur für uns beobachter und
journalisten sondern auch für die
abgeordneten war als olaf scholz am
sonntag um 11 eine regierungserklärung
abgab und das volle programm darstellte
bestehend aus fünf punkten und zwar hat
es vorher fraktionssitzung gegeben wo es
aber nur andeutungsweise die punkte
angesprochen wurden also waffenlieferung
waren bekannt aber
dazu kam dann 100 milliarden euro
man glaubt es kaum sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr außerdem die
übererfüllung des 2 prozent ziels das
noch die grünen zum beispiel vorher als
absolut willkürlich bezeichnet hat nicht
erfüllen wollten lng flüssiggas
terminals an
der nordsee in not zu helfen
und dazu noch ein ausstieg oder eine
einschränkung des swift-abkommens genau
das war alles die inzwischen schon
historische
bundestagssitzungen am sonntag um 11 uhr
die wurde schon relativ schnell
anberaumten aber diese
regierungserklärung die olaf scholz da
vorgelegt hat die hahn hatte es
tatsächlich in sich und wir wollen jetzt
uns noch mal genau ansehen was es
letztendlich damit auf sicht hat womit
wollen wir denn anfangen weil wir das
sondervermögen jetzt zunächst uns mal
genau angucken das ist ja für unsere
streitkräfte also für die
runtergewirtschaftet die bundeswehr ein
unfassbar wichtiges signal 100
milliarden euro kommen noch mal oben
drauf also es ein so genannte über
jährlicher etat auch ein sonder etat der
eben nicht in den normalen haushalt
einfließt und der den schon bestehenden
etat von 50 milliarden euro
der bundeswehr
aufstockt ja also damit kann man schon
einiges machen aber die konstruktion ist
in der tat interessant genau ist es ist
ja nicht im haushalt 20 20 drin ist
sondern irgendwann 22 gedacht oh gott
2022 ja genau das muss man vielleicht
einfach noch mal erklären diese funktion
des sondervermögens ist etwas was
durchaus bekannt ist was wir schon
häufiger getan als letzte mal als wir
zum beispiel darüber geredet haben war
im zusammenhang mit dem ahrtal mit
diesen fürchterlichen mit der
jahrhundertflut die da im vor allen
dingen nordrhein-westfalen und
rheinland-pfalz überschwemmt hat und
dazu unfassbaren schäden geführt hat
schon damals das war im herbst oder im
frühherbst wurden schon sehr schnell 50
milliarden euro
sondervermögen auf den weg gebracht das
ist so eine ähnliche konstruktion
allerdings haben wir hier noch mal die
und dass das ganze im grundgesetz
verankert werden soll vielleicht um noch
ein wort zu verlieren über den zustand
der bundeswehr der ist ja allgemein
beklagt aber bei einem wert von 50
milliarden euro zuletzt ist das
vielleicht ein bisschen
erklärungsbedürftig denn so viel weniger
ist das ja gar nicht als das was in
frankreich zum beispiel
ausgegeben wird oder auch in
großbritannien
also das ist und selbst russland kann da
noch nicht mal mithalten das ist
vielleicht auch mal eine interessante
konstellation aber jedenfalls
liegt das problem auch nicht darin dass
wir jetzt diese 50 milliarden haben im
veritas sondern die jahrzehnte zuvor
eigentlich die bundeswehr so sagen viele
die sich sehr intensiv damit beschäftigt
haben ausgehungert haben buchstäblich na
also wir erinnern uns mit dem
zusammenbruch des warschauer paktes im
jahr 1990 hatte man das gefühl
na ja wir sind die welt ist eine andere
der kalte krieg ist vorbei
die bundeswehr kann sich jetzt auf
andere dinge stürzen mit um andere dinge
kümmern was wir in den friedensdividende
die sogenannte
und dann haben wir auch schon gesehen
die wurden natürlich eingesetzt im
ausland wir haben ja über afghanistan
hier auch schon englisch gesprochen in
mali sind sie immer noch auch in litauen
sind ja einige stationiert also da gibt
es immer noch
situationen wo die bundeswehr natürlich
auch sehr viel gutes tut aber im
wesentlich kleineren umfang als das was
man braucht um ein land zu verteidigen
denn das muss man ja mal deutlich sagen
und gleichzeitig wurde auch extrem
an den geräten gespart ja also viele
panzer zum beispiel u boote hubschrauber
da gibt es etliche die gar nicht
geschäftsfähig sind wir haben ein
debakel um die sturmgewehre
schon vor sieben jahren hatte man den
entschluss gefasst neue sturm wie
gewehre zu kaufen für die soldatinnen
und soldaten
120.000 stück und das ist ein verfahren
das immer noch nicht abgeschlossen ist
weil es einerseits extrem kompliziert
war und dann auch noch zu
rechtsstreitigkeiten zwischen den
herstellern heckler & koch und die hähne
geführt hat die wings heute an diesem
mittwoch vor dem oberlandesgericht
düsseldorf verhandelt werden womöglich
zuletzt verhandelt werden aber daran
sieht man mal wo das problem in der
bundeswehr nicht so und jetzt versucht
man da sehr sehr viel geld drauf zu
kippen
da wird sich auch noch viel an den
strukturen ändern müssen im
beschaffungswesen aber jedenfalls sind
diese 100 milliarden euro erst mal im
raum übrigens noch nicht lange noch
nicht in der kasse was man deutlich
sagen sie sind erst angekündigt und das
wird sich in den nächsten jahren dann
erst zeigen vielleicht noch ein wort
über die juristische konstruktion hat er
ja schon gesagt also das ist etwas was
quasi neben dem haushalt steht und wo
auch die schuldenbremse da nicht
dazwischenfunken kann ja die haben wir
ja spätestens seit 2009 der vorher gab
es schon eingeschränkt aber seit 2009
ist sie in einer schönheit im
grundgesetz verankert der eigentlich
darf der bund nur maximal 0,35 prozent
der wirtschaftsleistung an neuen
schulden aufnehmen das sind ungefähr 13
milliarden euro das ist schon lange
lange drüber auch wegen der korona krise
aber das hat er schon über sie jetzt ja
sowieso ausgesetzt ist nur noch dieses
jahr richtig und das ist ja auch möglich
eine in dieser konstruktion bei der
schulen schuldenbremse da gibt es ja
ausnahmen wie zum beispiel
naturkatastrophen oder außergewöhnlichen
notsituationen genannt sind und da sagt
man ja ganz klar corona väter darunter
das wurde auch von niemandem jemals
bestritten das problem ist nur bei der
bundeswehr haben wir ein ganz anderes
eine ganz andere situation dann geht es
ja wieder eine naturkatastrophe noch um
eine außergewöhnliche notsituation
sondern der desolat der zustand der
bundeswehr ist ein strukturelles problem
und deswegen kann der eigentlich nicht
darunter fallen und wir haben jetzt hier
die möglichkeit das grundgesetz zu
verankern also politisch auf eine sehr
sehr breite basis zu stellen der will
bundeskanzler olaf scholz auch die cdu
mit ins boot hole die da auf jeden fall
mitmachen die finden das ja genau
richtig wobei sie auch anmerken das hat
friedrich merz der neue
fraktionsvorsitzende in seiner rede am
sonntag gesagt das mag sein das mag
vermögen heißt in wahrheit natürlich
sind es schulden und das stimmt ja auch
uns selbst wenn man das rechtlich so
hinbekommt dass es irgendwie mit der
schuldenbremse nicht konfiguriert ist
es ja am ende eigentlich nur umgehung
oder wie würdest du sehen ihr habt also
brachten sagen dass viele letztendlich
finde ich das aber den sauberen weg als
das was wir jetzt ja gesehen haben im
nachtragshaushalt 20 21 das haben wir
hier glaube ich im podcast noch nicht
besprochen ich hab das mal ein bisschen
länger aufgedröselt für den podcast für
deutschland und da auch mit dem
finanzstaatssekretär
florian tonka darüber gesprochen die
kann ich auch meine show zu tun aber da
gab es ärger weil die bundesregierung
auch unter dem neuen
bundesfinanzminister
christian lindner sich entschlossen hat
ja corona geht im grunde kroner kredite
in höhe von 60 milliarden euro um zu
widmen die brauchte man gott sei dank in
der krise nicht aber steckt sie jetzt in
den klimafonds da gehört sie eigentlich
nicht hin mehr so sagt jedenfalls die
union die die ampel rechtfertigt das
natürlich damit dass sie sagen ja wir
müssen jetzt ja die wirtschaft wieder
ankurbeln wir müssen aus dem corona noch
wieder rauskommen und dafür brauchen wir
investitionen und die tätigen wir noch
besser in die zukunft nämlich in
umweltschutz und klimaschutz so war die
konstellation da die union war empört
hat schon angedroht eine abstrakte
normenkontrolle vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht
einzureichen und das ganze mal
überprüfen zu lassen und das ist ja hier
auch der nebeneffekt durch die
verankerung im grundgesetz
dass man das einmal auf eine sehr sehr
breite basis stellt eben die
zwei-drittel-mehrheit zur änderung des
grundgesetzes bemüht denn stets drin
kann auch nicht für was anderes benutzt
werden und
da fing es nämlich tatsächlich schon an
weil ja tatsächlich die auch
insbesondere die grünen
fraktionsmitglieder so überrascht wurden
von dieser summe von der sie aber auch
die spd wusste davon vorher nichts
wahrscheinlich auch nicht die fdp
sie hatten gehört irgendwie im vorfeld
der der der bundestagsdebatte es gibt
wohl eine so eine art sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr aber diese 100 milliarden
hatten sie noch nicht gehört und
dass also das thema aufrüstung ist ja
für linke parteien ein ganz schwieriges
für die grünen insbesondere die
natürlich sich als pazifistische partei
nach wie vor verstehen und da fängt es
ja schon an wir haben in diesen tagen
ein interview geführt mit der
parlamentarischen geschäftsführerin
irene mihalic von den grünen die schon
sagt naja wir schauen uns dann mal an
wofür das geld dann wirklich ausgegeben
wird sie verstehe sicherheit umfassend
sagt sie und das ist nicht nur
aufrüstung und bundeswehr sondern das
kann auch sein entwicklungshilfe es kann
sogar sein klimaschutz denn wie
christian lindner jetzt gesagt hat
erneuerbare energien sind sogenannte
freiheitsentziehende uns befreien von
der abhängigkeit von russland und
insofern sei das auch alles
sicherheitsrelevant und also sie fängt
jetzt schon an das geld im kopf ganz
breit zu verteilen olaf scholz
allerdings hat tatsächlich gesprochen
vom sondervermögen bundeswehr was
bedeuten würde es soll auch nur für die
bundeswehr benutzt werden wo jetzt aber
auch grüne schon sagen na ja ja
deren es aus deren sich dann auch aus
sicht der spd war die beschaffung oder
das geld nie das problem sondern es ging
eher um strukturelle fragen im
beschaffungswesen was dann
strukturiert werden müsste und all das
und natürlich ist auch die frage was
kann man eigentlich so schnell
beschaffen das sind ja alles
teilweise sind die waffen noch gar nicht
hergestellt aber die rüstungsindustrie
ist im rausch wird rüstungsindustrie
sind glaube ich die einzigen aktien die
jetzt geboren und da kann ich übrigens
auch noch mal darauf verweisen haben wir
in der pz mein kollege uli friese hat
sehr interessante umfragen gemacht unter
den rüstungskonzernen die es in
deutschland ja durchaus gibt ja die
vielleicht auch viel gespielt waren aber
die natürlich jetzt auch ihre
bereitschaft signalisieren angesichts
des geldflusses und sagen wir können
unsere
produktionskapazitäten enorm
aufstocken ja also interessante debatte
ich glaube auch diese einigkeit die wird
vielleicht nicht lange währen und da
wird jetzt sehr stark darauf ankommen
wie man das genau formuliert die
gesetzesänderung er und da sagen eben
auch die grünen und andere
parlamentarier das parlament hat das
haushaltsrecht und da wollen wir doch
mal sehen ja die einigkeit ist sowieso
ein sag ich mal großes wort natürlich
gibt es eine politische einigkeit aber
dieses programm das olaf scholz am
sonntag präsentiert hat ist in erster
linie ein olaf scholz programm das er wo
er seinen anderen ministern vorher
bescheid gegeben hat er hat sich mit
einigen auch intensiver ausgetauscht
aber am ende hat erst beschlossen und
tatsächlich auch die parlamentarier da
vor vollendete tatsachen gestellt aber
die gesetze müssen wir erst noch gemacht
werden wie wichtig vielleicht darf ich
da einen haken findest du denn jetzt
oder wie richtig findest du die 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr denn ich
fand ja ganz interessant am sonntag
dieser einigkeit war ja schon
bemerkenswert vielleicht lag sie auch in
der gewisse sprachlosigkeit bei leuten
die überrumpelt wurden langsam regt sich
da schon widerstand und das wird immer
mehr auch die kritik laut die sagt na ja
einerseits natürlich was du sagst es ein
geld allein liegt das nicht aber geld
dann wiederum kann natürlich auch sehr
helfen vor allen dingen wenn wir ja vier
geräten noch nach beschaffen müssen das
sehr relativ umstritten aber die frage
ist ja wie ohne umstritten diese
aufrüstung
also zum einen ich glaube auch hier
einigkeit wenn man sich genau angeschaut
hat teile der spd und grünen fraktion
haben an diesen momenten der rede nicht
geklatscht haben teilweise sogar mit dem
kopf geschüttelt also die haben schon
signalisiert dass sie das
sind teil nicht richtig finden wobei sie
jetzt alle sagen unterm strich ist also
für die grünen geht dieser satz es ist
nicht gut aber es ist notwendig ja also
sie tragen dass jetzt alle mit und sagen
dann alles weitere muss man im detail
schauen ich glaube diese 100 milliarden
euro sind erst mal ein ganz klares
signal und zwar nicht nur nach innen und
an russland sondern auch an die
alliierten und die partner im westen
also wenn in der new york times und
einen amerikanischen zeitungen steht
deutschland investiert 100 milliarden
euro in seine aufrüstung dann ist es
halt ein ganz deutliches zeugnis eine
sprache die die welt versteht die sagt
deutschland hält sich nicht mehr frei
raus wie das in der vergangenheit war
und spricht immer viel von
internationaler verantwortung und wenn
es darauf ankommt um es mal so hart zu
sagen lässt das land andere die
drecksarbeit machen und sagte nein auf
und aufgrund unserer historischen
verantwortung können wir nicht so weiter
alles schwierig parlamentsarmee und so
sondern sagt halt wir sind jetzt dabei
ihr könnt auf uns zählen und interessant
war auch robert habeck heute morgen der
ja gerade in amerika ist und sagte ja
die amerikaner haben das zeichen
verstanden dass deutschland jetzt ein
starker partner ist und ich glaube darum
ging es jetzt mal in aller erster linie
und das weitere was gesagt die
bundeswehr hat natürlich große defizite
in ihrer operativen funktionsfähigkeit
komme vielleicht zum thema
waffenlieferung auch das ist ja ein
thema was immer ausgeschlossen wurde von
denen insbesondere linken parteien aber
auch die cdu auch angela merkel hat in
ihren ganzen jahren immer gesagt
keine waffenlieferungen in krisengebiete
so stand's in den verschiedenen
koalitionsverträgen drin so stand es
auch zuletzt natürlich in den
wahlprogrammen von grünen und auch der
spd drin und der gedanke war immer dass
man in krisengebieten durch
waffenlieferungen nur den blutzoll
erhöht ja das ist dann um es mal so hart
und zynisch zu sagen das leiden und den
blutzoll der unterliegenden schwächeren
partei
konfliktpartei verlängert jetzt war es
aber so dass in so habe ich das mir
erzählen lassen insbesondere diese
bilder von selbst gebaute molotow
cocktails in kiew dazu geführt haben
dass die weltgemeinschaft und eben auch
deutschland gesagt hat da können wir
nicht länger zu gucken apropos
weltgemeinschaft die haben ja schon alle
geliefert deutschland war in europa das
einzige land das bislang gar nichts
gemacht hatte und da hat man dann gesagt
es das geht einfach nicht wir müssen
etwas tun und hat sich entschieden
1000 panzerfäuste zu liefern und 500
sogenannte stinger raketen das sind
raketen die man soweit ich das weiß von
der schulter aus abschießen kann und die
ich weiß es nicht ganz gerade reichweite
aber die so wurde mir das erzählt doch
auch sehr
mächtig sind rund 200 panzer und so
weiter genau treffen können und die
anders als panzerfäuste die wirklich nur
im nahkampf oder fast also muss man
schon auf 200 meter also dran kommen als
jüngere kind natürlich über größere
distanzen wirken abgesehen davon dass
auch waffenlieferungen hat deutschland
die genehmigung gegeben einerseits von
estland und andererseits von den
niederlanden weil es in deutschland
dieses sogenannte and verwendung prinzip
der waffen gibt es heißt waffen die in
deutschland hergestellt sind selbst wenn
die zwischenzeitlich in ein anderes land
wie etwa die niederlande exportiert
werden wenn die niederlande sie dann in
ein krisengebiet gibt muss deutschland
zustimmen oder überhaupt was mit denen
macht muss deutschland also diese ent
verbleibs gibt es eine art von von
ischämischen klausel halt nur eine
klausel in den verträgen die noch immer
sagt wenn es weiter verwendet wird muss
deutschland zustimmen also das ist alles
frei gegeben worden und rechtlich ist es
ja gibt es vielleicht einige fragen das
eine ist natürlich im koalitionsvertrag
steht anders drin das haben wir ja schon
häufiger aber besprochen
koalitionsvertrag ist eine
absichtserklärung die letztlich die
parteien theoretisch findet aber die
parteien das haben wir sehr sehr sehr
oft gesehen können sich auch entscheiden
das ganz anders zu machen und in
vielerlei hinsicht ist der
koalitionsvertrag jetzt obsolet naja wer
muss man genau was muss man sehen aber
in dieser hinsicht auf jeden fall die
andere frage hat kai ambos professor für
straf und völkerrecht der uni göttingen
und hatte aufgeworfen uns einen text
dazu geschickt zu über den wir für den
wir sehr danken und er hat die frage
aufgeworfen ins wiefern eigentlich die
lieferung von war deutschen waffen an
die ukraine eine verletzung des
neutralitätsgebot sind und er hat gesagt
naja in nord realitäts gebot ist
natürlich ein prinzip des humanitären
völkerrechts dass ein start wäre eine
konfliktpartei unterstützt verletzt
letztlich das neutralitätsgebot
des staates und dann hat er aber sehr
klar die antwort gegeben die finde ich
auch wirklich sehr sehr plausibel ist
das natürlich diese frage ist
neutralitätsgebot in diesem fall
jedenfalls wirklich rein akademischer
natur ist weil sie völlig überlagert
wird durch das selbstverteidigungsrecht
und natürlich auch das recht von
nothilfe also die ukraine die am
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
ausgesetzt es hat natürlich nach artikel
51 der un-charta das recht sich selbst
zu verteidigen und andere staaten haben
das recht dabei zu helfen und zwar in
jeglicher hinsicht nicht nur durch eine
tatsächlich militärische unterstützung
mit soldaten und und eigenen flugzeugen
sondern auch mit lieferung von waffen
also quasi eine form der nothilfe weil
man so will und in dieser das ist so
offensichtlich dass die fragen von
neutralitätsgebot sich da dann also dass
das völlig verdrängt wird und insofern
ist es keine frage die man aufwerfen
kann die vielleicht an einem
völkerrechtlichen prüfungsgespräch auch
mal aufkommen könnte die aber glaube ich
sehr klar zu beantworten ist dazu kann
man vielleicht nochmal erwähnen dass
diese text von professor am bus auf dem
verfassungs blog zu erschienen ist und
da auch nachgelesen werden kann also für
alle diejenigen die es noch genauso ein
genauer wissen möchten das können wir ja
gerne rein stellen in die show nutzt
auch das
dann kommen wir jetzt zu einem weiteren
punkt der ja sich erst mal primär in
deutschland
abspielt wo jetzt aber die die
bundestagsentscheidung erst mal nichts
mit zu tun haben nämlich die frage der
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine wir sehen ja
bilder von unendlichen staus von
ukrainern die sich auf den weg machen
richtung polen richtung slowakei
wahnsinnige staus an den grenzen weil
das ist interessant es liegt eben nicht
an den polen oder
slowaken und ungarn und um gehören die
sie nicht durchlassen sondern es liegt
tatsächlich an den ukrainischen
grenzposten die erstens nicht so richtig
gut besetzt sind weil die menschen eben
im krieg sind und kämpfen und zweitens
weil sie die leute kontrollieren weil
die männer im wehrfähigen alter und das
ist in der ukraine derzeit wirklich sehr
großzügig wird das verstanden nicht
ausreisen dürfen das heißt frauen kinder
und sehr alte männer werden rausgelassen
alle anderen müssen bleiben und das
führt eben zu diesen staus so jetzt ist
die frage es gibt jetzt in deutschland
gerald knaus hat es gestern abend im zdf
gesagt der migrationsexperte sagte es
könnte sein dass es millionen menschen
gibt die nach deutschland kommen wir
dürfen nicht vergessen die ukraine hat
40 millionen
staatsangehörige das ist halb so viel
wie deutschland
derzeit sind es aber noch gar nicht so
viele also etwa
500.000 menschen haben so ungefähr das
land verlassen eine gute halbe million
hat sich jetzt schon auf den weg mache
ich auf den jahr oder ist schon über die
grenze glaube ich in den nachbarländern
aber es sind halt nur in deutschland
sind bislang nur in anführungszeichen
5000 menschen registriert worden also
das sind nicht so viele und viele von
denen die hier ankommen sagen auch wir
wollen gar nicht hier bleiben sondern
wir haben bekannte verwandte freunde zum
beispiel in portugal da scheint es also
deutschland mehr derzeit sieht es so aus
ein transitland zu sein das ist alles
noch
in der sage ich mal wir sind jetzt
mittendrin man kann ist es viel zu früh
irgendetwas wirklich zu sagen wie sich
diese migrationsbewegung
weiterentwickeln es werden sicherlich
auch menschen in deutschland bleiben es
sind aber derzeit wirklich weniger als
gedacht und die meisten kommen bei
verwandten und freunden unter die
erstaufnahmeeinrichtung die jetzt von
den kommunen teilweise wieder
hochgefahren wurden dina in den jahren
nach 215 aufgebaut worden sind alles
andere als voll also wirklich alles
anders weil sie sind quasi leer aber das
interessante ist ja dass ich auf der
anderen seite rechtlich relativ viel tut
nämlich die eu ist sich in puncto
flüchtlinge so einig wie nie zu erklären
er wirklich total interessant genau es
gab jetzt ja schon ein treffen der innen
und justizminister und auch auf ebene
der staats und regierungschefs wurde das
thema besprochen und da sind sich
wirklich alle einig die flüchtlinge aus
der ukraine mit offenen armen zu
begrüßen selbst viktor orban hat gesagt
meine tür ungarische stürze viertel
genau der sonst immer dagegen gehalten
hat bei sich der verteilung von
flüchtlingen aus syrien zum beispiel
entgegengestemmt hat und sogar geklagt
hat vor dem europäischen gerichtshof
gegen eine quote die ihr aufnehmen
sollte und so weiter hat jetzt gesagt
wir nehmen gerne auf das ist natürlich
auch deshalb eine andere situation weil
dass diese länder in osteuropa jetzt die
erst ankunfts länder sind anders als
in der anderen flüchtlingssituation es
gibt doch sehr enge verbindung zu der
ukraine in polen gegen ungarn in
slowenien weil das sind schon ohnehin
schon viele familiäre verbindungen oder
auch aber als berufliche verbindungen
viele ukraine arbeiten darunter das
ganze zunächst irgendwie befürchtungen
dass die polen die ukraine vielleicht
nicht so gut behandeln könnten waren so
weil es da auch wohl in teilen der
bevölkerung jedenfalls so einen latenten
rassismus gibt davon ist aber derzeit
wirklich gott sei dank überhaupt nichts
zu merken vielleicht ist es auch ein
vorteil
das kann ich nicht beurteilen jedenfalls
derzeit sind die polen zeigen sich sehr
sehr hilfsbereit aber auf die eu-ebene
zurückzukommen es ist nicht nur eine
einigkeit die menschen aufzunehmen
sondern will jetzt auch morgen abend
also donnerstagabend bei einem weiteren
einen rat die sogenannte massenzustrom
richtlinie aktivieren ein in deutscher
übersetzung wirklich kein schöner die
häusliche der wurde nach den
balkankriegen wurde diese richtlinie
geschaffen und wenn die
innenminister mit qualifizierter
mehrheit sozusagen entschließen das ein
fall der richtlinie nämlich einen
massenzustrom an schutzbedürftigen
eintritt dann führt das dazu dass in
deutschland § 24 des aufenthaltsgesetzes
aktiviert wird und das will ich jetzt
nur kurz darstellen was das für
konsequenzen hat es führt dazu dass
ukraine ein aufenthaltsrecht bekommen in
deutschland also nicht asyl beantragen
müssen es ist also ein sehr
unbürokratisches verhalten noch nicht
ganz klar ob die ausländerbehörden oder
das bamf also das bundesamt für
migration und flüchtlinge diesen
aufenthalt titel verleiht der ist
zunächst für ein jahr kann aber auch
unkompliziert auf drei jahre verlängert
werden klammer auf ukrainer mit einem
biometrischen pass dürfen sowieso nach
deutschland einreisen visumsfrei und
dürfen 90 tage hier bleiben dazu gibt es
noch weitere erleichterungen praktischer
natur zum beispiel dass die bahn gesagt
hat man braucht keine fahrkarten und
ähnliches also neben diesem
aufenthaltsrecht von 1 bis zu drei
jahren gibt es auch die möglichkeit die
familie nachzuholen zwar nicht das ist
ein bisschen eingeschränkt das kann nur
die familie sein mit der man in der
ukraine vorher schon zusammen gewohnt
hat und wo sozusagen das familiäre
zusammenleben durch gerade durch den
ausbruch des krieges zerstört wurde aber
das dürfte ja bei vielen familien der
fall sein es gibt keine sofortige
arbeitserlaubnis keine automatische
außer selbstständig tätig zu sein aber
es kann die auf die arbeitserlaubnis
erteilt werden das steht in paragraf 4
abs genau nachlesen will des
aufenthaltsgesetzes und was auch
interessant ist ist die
zuweisung der
flüchtlinge auf die bundesländer das ist
ja auch hier wie in der flüchtlingskrise
sonst nach dem sogenannten königsteiner
schlüssel also da wird aus verschiedenen
faktoren von bevölkerung und
wirtschaftskraft und so weiter die
jeweilige quote für die bundesländer aus
geriet ausgerechnet und danach werden
die zugewiesen
sie haben dann und dass es ganz
interessant müssen sie auch tatsächlich
in diesem bundesland sich aufhalten es
gibt ebenso steht das ausdrücklich ein
paar 24 kein recht als ich seinen
wohnort
also einen bestimmten wohnort sich
auszusuchen
aber man hat keine pflicht etwa eine
erstaufnahmeeinrichtung oder ähnlichem
zu bleiben und vielleicht noch als
letzten punkt was der unterschied ist zu
diesen zu diesem verteilungssystem dass
wir auf europäischer ebene in der
flüchtlingskrise 215 folgende hatten was
ja nie so richtig gut funktioniert hat
ist dass es hier
tatsächlich keine kein zwang ist von den
eu mitgliedsstaaten flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen sondern es ist rein
freiwillig also diese massen zuschuss
richtlinie regelt nicht die verteilung
sondern regelt wirklich das verfahren
das anwendbar ist wenn ein staat
flüchtlinge aufnimmt das licht war
dadurch in halle 13 stellt sich das
problem nicht und dadurch dass es
bislang ebenfalls gar nicht so viele
sind und die die es sind eben bislang
privat unterkommen aber wir müssen halt
sehen diese diese krise und der
kriegsausbruchs noch nicht mal eine
woche her also viele werden sich jetzt
auch erst nach und nach auf den weg
machen und hierher kommen dass also zu
den flüchtlingen kommen wir jetzt kurz
zum
europarat also was man jetzt ja auf
breiter front sieht muss man ja sagen
ist ja dass russland geächtet wird auf
vielen verschiedenen ebenen also da gibt
es ausschlüsse noch und nöcher auch
jenseits der sanktionen die wir jetzt
gleich hören werden die du mit uefa und
fifa zum beispiel so gut aus dem esc aus
dem european song contest das macht man
dann immer so ein bisschen belächeln
aber aber das finde ich übrigens total
interessant wenn ich das ganz gut sagen
darf man hat ja immer oder ich hab immer
gedacht wir leben in dieser demokratien
die natürlich die beste frauen ist
politisch wie man leben kann und
trotzdem hatte man immer den eindruck
ist es alles so schwerfällig und
entscheidungen werden immer
irgendwie es dauert alles wahnsinnig
lang und bis man sich einigt und einer
schießt immer quer und dann so und man
ist sich europa sowieso nie einig und
auf der welt geben und dann ziehen
wieder die fußball verbände oder
irgendjemand wieder nicht mit und jetzt
hat man schon den eindruck dass
angriffskrieg hat die lage insofern
verändert dass jetzt alle sagen so jetzt
aber richtig und dann hat man sanktions
pakete auf allen bereichen und die auf
einmal die fifa selbst schalke trennt
sich von dem langjährigen sponsor
gazprom nur gehirnströme ja noch kein
einsehen aber tatsächlich alle anderen
akteure ziehen an einem strang und das
ist auch dass man so denkt okay das
haben wir ehrlich zeit in der kroner
krise natürlich auch schon gesehen aber
dass man sagt okay wenn es sein muss und
wenn es wirklich ernst wird dann ist der
westen trotz der komplizierten
strukturen absolut handlungsfähig und
das finde ich mal in den vielen vielen
schlimmen über das wir reden ein
positives signal ja sehr gut dass du das
mal heraus das stimmt natürlich absolut
und jetzt im blick blicken wir ganz kurz
eben noch auf den europarat neben diesen
ganzen dinge wie jetzt schon genannt
haben ist das natürlich auch interessant
was ich da tut denn der europarat hat
russland suspendiert und auch da eben
ein klares und bisher nie da gewesenes
signal gesendet vielleicht nochmal für
alle die die bisschen kram müssen da
gehöre ich durchaus auch dazu was ist
eigentlich der euro partner ist eine
internationale organisation mit sitz in
französisch im französischen straßburg
gern im schönen kleinen städtchen und er
hat wirklich wenig zu tun mit der
europäischen union auch wenn man immer
das gefühl hat das klingt irgendwie mit
aber tatsächlich sind da wesentlich
größer sind 47 mitgliedsstaaten
inklusive übrigens russland und die
ukraine und am europa rat dranhängt die
parlamentarische versammlung also
tatsächlich so eine art von parlament
und aber vor allen dingen denen uns der
uns alle bekannte gerichtshof für
menschenrechte also der igm erde auf
über die wahrung der menschenrechte
wacht so und lage ist die mrk dies auch
ein bekannt europäische
menschenrechtskonvention
ja so und was bedeutet das jetzt wenn
der europarat
russland suspendiert da das bedeutet
nichts anderes als dass dem land also
russland jetzt vorübergehend seine
vertretungs rechte entzogen werden das
klingt jetzt vielleicht nach viel nicht
viel aber es ist ein deutliches signal
basis ist artikel 8 der statuten des
europarats und da droht eben die
suspendierung wenn der respekt der
rechtsstaatlichkeit der menschenrechte
und der grundfreiheiten
schwerwiegend verletzt wurde und ja also
donnerstagabend im am 24 februar konnte
man das recht schnell schon feststellen
und schon da wo das ihm
festgestellt und das hatte dann ihm
diese
konsequenz und das hat aber nicht die
konsequenz aus russland etwa nicht mehr
verurteilt werden könnte oder genau das
ist sozusagen der vorteil muss man ja
sagen dass russland nicht im hohen bogen
raus geschmissen wird sondern quasi die
repräsentations rechte suspendiert
werden das noch immer der russische
richter also am gericht sitzt und auch
immer noch fälle angenommen werden
können das ist natürlich gegen russland
also das ist wäre natürlich die
konsequenz vor dem egmr können eben nur
fälle vorgebracht werden gegen
mitglieder also die sich quasi den
statuten auch unterworfen genau das
wurde in der vergangenheit immer
vorgebracht gegen einen rauswurf von
ländern weil man dann sagt also es wurde
immer gesagt es ist wichtig dass man
dieses gremium hat und den europäischen
gerichtshof für menschenrechte um auch
partner in russland klar zu benennen und
zu verurteilen
das ja etliche verurteilung gegen
russland ich glaube man auch in
zusammenhang mit mittlerweile ja genau
mein losgehen würde ich sagen auch er
und andere fälle
auch im konflikt mit georgien usw
buttercreme auch ne und der gegeben
genau das wird kommt immer wieder vor
dem gerichtshof und das ist für diese
länder ein wichtiges gremium wie
übrigens die türkei auch mitglied ist
und auch da wird immer wieder betont wie
wichtig das ist man kann umgekehrt
natürlich sagen ja also bringt natürlich
auch wenig wenn es urteile gibt die dann
im nachgang keinen effekt haben die
eigentlich ignoriert werden in weiten
teilen aber es setzt immerhin ein signal
und interessant ist übrigens das sowieso
schon seit längerem einen konflikt
gehabt zwischen dem zwischen dem
europarat und russland weißrussland
nämlich genau das gemacht hat und gesagt
hat wir erkennen die urteile nicht ohne
weiteres an sondern unsere eigene
verfassungsgerichtsbarkeit prüft erst
mal was die da so entschieden haben und
ob es überhaupt mandats im
verfassungsrecht vereinbar ist und gibt
dann ein ok oder ein nicht okay und das
ist natürlich gerade nicht der sinn vom
völkerrecht dass ein nationales gericht
da noch mal ein veto einlegen kann und
deswegen gab es schon länger schwierige
verhandlungen und bisher kein ergebnis
und das ist also ein bekannter konflikt
und der sich jetzt natürlich noch mal
durch die suspendierung deutlich
verschärft
[Musik]
ja und dann kommen jetzt zum schluss
bevor wir gleich zu den sanktionen
überwechseln nochmals russia today kurz
rt ein propagandasender
deutschsprachiger propagandasender der
russischen regierung der sich hier schon
seit geraumer zeit in deutschland breit
macht auch auf großer front hier in
berlin sehr aktiv ist einerseits dadurch
dass ich glaube fast alle
journalisten in der berliner babbel
glaube ich schon mal ein angebot
bekommen haben dazu arbeiten sich durch
übrigens noch nicht ich hab da habe ich
zwei willkommen helene war aber auch
wirklich nicht besonders attraktiv und
auch wenn ich sehr personalisierte so
viel kann ich fühlte mich nicht
geschmeichelt aber jedenfalls konnte man
die aktivitäten sehen
dass ich hier wirklich mit großer großer
wucht versucht wird dieses das rt
fernsehen in deutschland zu etablieren
um auch hier die russische propaganda
maschine zum laufen zu bekommen so dazu
muss man vielleicht sagen vielleicht
kennen eben viele russia today nicht
seit 9 2009 übrigens heißt es jetzt rt
ich finde das immer nicht so ganz
griffig deswegen gehe ich oft wird sich
oft in den alten namen noch nur für alle
die sich dann darüber wundern er wird
vollständig vom russischen staat
finanziert mutterorganisation ist tv
nowosti in moskau so und jetzt haben wir
hier in deutschland in konkreten in
berlin die rtg produktions gmbh die
mitte dezember auf sendung gegangen ist
und zwar interessanterweise ohne eine
deutsche
sendelizenz zu haben also normalerweise
bevor man ihm auf sendung geht muss man
diesen antrag stellen und dann muss man
verschiedene
eigentlich glaube ich nicht so
wahnsinnig schwierig die zu bekommen nur
man muss eben
staatsfernsehen ja also das gebot der
staatsferne ist etwas was in medien
staatsvertrag genau festgelegt ist was
auch vom bundesverfassungsgericht schon
abgesegnet wurde wo man einfach nicht
dran vorbei kommt und nicht nur
staatsferne zum deutschen staat sondern
eben auch zum römischen heißt es wichtig
genau als generell soll eine
unabhängigkeit der berichterstattung
gewährleistet sein dazu auch vielleicht
noch mal deutlich der hinweis da geht es
auch nicht um inhaltskontrolle sondern
um journalistische standards und zu
denen gehört sticht auch eine
unabhängigkeit und zwar egal von wem
außer den abonnenten natürlich
aber das haben die interessanterweise
gar nicht erst versucht sondern sie
ahnten schon dass das mit der
staatsferne da nicht so hinkommt und
haben sich dann zunächst mal in
luxemburg um eine sendelizenz bemüht der
sind sie aber nicht gehört worden auch
mit dem argument wurde das dann
abgeschmettert also dass die einfach
hier in ihren sitz in deutschland haben
und dass dort schon natürlich zuständig
erst dann sind sie nach sehr haben
hingegangen und haben da
interessanterweise eine sendelizenz
bekommen
und sind dann eben auf sendung gegangen
mit dem argument na ja also wir haben
herz einer und warum könnte die gültig
seien in deutschland auf grundlage des
europäischen übereinkommens über das
grenzüberschreitende
fernsehen kurz ict aber es ist eine
klare umgehungs konstruktion ja sehr
schön man merkt dass sie durch unter
juristen ist also so geht's nicht ja
sagt man die zuständigen gremien und
dann sind auch sehr sehr schnell schon
eingeschritten also die medienanstalt
berlin-brandenburg hat ihr verfahren
gleich am 17 dezember öffnet also ein
tag danach haben sich das genau
angeguckt und die kommission zur
zulassung und aufsicht hatte die
bundesweite ausstrahlung des
fernsehprogramms rt de seit dem ersten
februar verboten ja und was macht er
ignorierte und sendet fleißig weiter und
jetzt gab es eben eine neue entwicklung
der medienanstalt berlin-brandenburg die
gesagt hat also dass man auch wenn ihr
jetzt nicht sofort eure sendungen da
einstellt dann gibt es ein zwangsgeld in
höhe von 25.000 euro und zwar habt ihr
eine frist bis zum vierten märz pro tag
oder pro das ist interessant ja pro tag
und dann
dagegen kann natürlich geklagt werden
das hat auch erträge getan aber also das
ist dann so ein hauptsacheverfahren was
ein bisschen länger dauert aber gegen
das zwangsgeld ist noch ist jetzt
natürlich das ist ganz frisch dass es
wurde glaube ich runter verhängt oder so
also jedenfalls erst ein paar tage alt
und
heute habe ich mit dem
verwaltungsgericht berlin gesprochen die
haben noch kein verfahren gehabt aber
sind schon
alarmiert und können denn auch sehr sehr
schnell darüber entscheiden und da geht
es dann im konkret um das zwangsgeld was
ich habe auch noch gehört also ursula
von der leyen hatte am vergangenen
wochenende auch im rahmen dieser
sanktions
androhungen und vereinbarung gesagt
russia today und übrigens auch sputnik
was ein ganz ähnlicher sender ist sollen
europaweit verboten werden und das läuft
jetzt wohl in deutschland dieser
auftrag der sich erstmal an die
mitgliedstaaten wendete bei der
sogenannten bkm also bei der
bundesbeauftragten für kultur und medien
claudia roth von den grünen die im
kanzleramt sitzt und sich damit befasst
und die wohl auch
jetzt noch mal dass es wahrscheinlich
parallel dazu in zusammenarbeit mit den
medienanstalten eben diesen europäischen
diese europäische vereinbarung
exekutiert wobei es in deutschland dann
dadurch dass keine lizenz gibt und die
notwendig ist wahrscheinlich ja gar
nicht so schwer sein sollte wenn sich
dann russia today rt mal an die
deutschen regeln halten
letztendlich wird das ganze flankiert
von so großen konzernen wie facebook und
google die auch schon gesagt hat wir
stoppen zb die verbreitung auf youtube
oder eben auch über meta
meta so heißt ihn schon so heißt es die
das unternehmen das facebook betreiben
also ich hab mich aber nicht funktional
angewöhnt ja aber gehört auch zum
facebook konzertes konzert
und kannst ja genau wie habe mir neulich
sagte sowieso ich bin ja eh nicht bei
facebook aber sie sagte man muss dann
auch nicht mehr hingehen es ist er
menschen die noch älter sind als ich
dann gibt es ja auch
so dass zum thema rt vielleicht noch
einen kurzen schlenker weil natürlich
auch in russland das ja nicht ignoriert
wurde nicht unbemerkt blieb dass wir
hier versuchen rt ja zur räson zu
bringen oder jedenfalls dazu zu bringen
sich an die regeln zu halten
da hat gab es ja im anfang februar gab
es ja einen gegenschlag schon von
russland dass nun vielleicht um den
kreis noch zu vervollständigen da gab es
die anordnung das büro der deutschen
welle in moskau zu schließen und
mitarbeitern die akkreditierung zu
entziehen ja und da gab es aber ihm
keine sehr ausgefeilte
begründung dafür sondern es wurde eben
schlicht als reaktion auf die dinge die
ja eher die dinge rund um rt gewertet
so und jetzt begrüße ich meinen kollegen
hendrik kafsack
wirtschaftskorrespondent in brüssel es
uns zugeschaltet um über das
sanktionspaket zu sprechen nunmehr das
dritte paket das die eu beschlossen hat
politisch beschlossen am vergangenen
sonntag die umsetzungsphase läuft noch
hendrik schön dass du bei uns bist
so ich möchte als erstes mal fragen
warum wird eigentlich warum werden die
sanktionen eigentlich auf europäischer
ebene beschlossen
naja ich werde auf europäischer ebene
sollten eng abgestimmt darüber hinaus
natürlich mit den vereinigten staaten
den kanal wir hatten uns den dritten
auch und warum auf europäischer ebene um
möglichst viel hoch entfalten zu können
und weil wenn es um finanzen geht
eigentlich auch schwer vorstellbar ist
dass da ein einzelner europäischer staat
agiert und ich nicht mit den anderen
abstimmen weil das ja alles
entsprechende folgewirkungen auch für
die anderen mitgliedstaaten hat also
kein zwingend rechtlicher grund dahinter
dass es irgendeine gemeinsame eu
kompetenz da gibt sondern es ist
eigentlich eher die die auswirkung die
sagt die schlagkraft hat es eben nur
wenn man in diesen fragen auch gemeinsam
vorgeht
das hält lässige bisschen davon aber was
sanktionen man schaut aber tatsächlich
natürlich schon vorstellbar dass die
mitgliedstaaten die einzeln agieren man
kann daran festmachen dass sich die luft
überflugrechte anschaut die ja auch im
laufe des sonntags erst von einer nach
dem anderen in russischen
fluggesellschaften aber russischen
privatperson erzogen worden sind dann am
ende aber schon auf europäischer ebene
um das ganze entsprechend koordiniert zu
machen hängt ein bisschen davon ab über
welche pakete und lechners von
sanktionen man genau dann steigen wir
doch jetzt da mal ein es gibt ja in
diesem paket 3 würde ich mal sagen im
hauptgruppen von sanktionen die sich
jetzt erstmal gegen russland richten das
erste nämlich die einschränkung des
swift abkommens wird als zum teil
jedenfalls als finanzielle atombombe
bezeichnet
wenngleich kannst du uns erst mal kurz
erklären was es überhaupt mit diesem
swift-abkommen auf sich hat wofür das
wichtig ist und welche konsequenzen ist
jetzt für russland hat dass sie nicht
mehr dabei sind
ich will das mal kurz was sagen
atombombe ist immer so ein begriff den
ich nehm zusammenhalt nicht so
wahnsinnig glücklich finde aber dass die
seite geschoben wenn über zu reden reden
wird ein zahlungsnetzwerk was zwischen
banken und anita ziert
11.000 banken die mal da auch
angeschlossen und die tauschen über
dieses netzwerk informationen auswendig
ein geschäft mache in einem land und ein
geschäft in einem anderen land dann
konsequenzen hat könnte zwei banken
beteiligt sind dann tauschen die sich
ausgleich ab ob die sozusagen das geld
was der eine zur verfügung stellt auch
wirklich gar ist und wie das überwiesen
werden kann et cetera gibt sich und
technik die geschäfte in der modernen
digitalisierten welt stattfinden
und für russland hat es die folge wenn
sie dann nicht mehr teilnehmen können
dass diese bankgeschäfts und wahnsinnig
kompliziert werden man kann das ganze
noch machen man kann ganz klassisch zum
beispiel wenig übel einkaufe und darum
geht's ja wenn oder gas wenn wir über
russland reden das auch ganz simpel per
fax machen indem sie ein fax schicken
und sage hiermit bestätige ich das geld
auf dem konto xy kann überwiesen werden
et cetera macht das ganze aber natürlich
immens kompliziert und auch teuer oder
damit auch teuer war kompliziert in der
modernen welt natürlich zwangsläufig
eigentlich auch immer gleich teurer halt
und und auch spürbar teurer deutschland
hat es sich ja mit dem dieser
einschränkung des swift abkommens für
russland schwer getan so war jedenfalls
in berlin zu hören am anfang war der
widerstand groß und das hauptargument
war eben dass wir ja nach wie vor sehr
viel der kohle und des gases dass wir in
deutschland verbrauchen aus russland
beziehen nämlich ungefähr die hälfte und
der westen insgesamt pro tag man glaubt
es kaum 600 millionen dollar für energie
an russland bezahlt immense summen und
die frage war halt wenn wir das nicht
mehr bezahlen können vielleicht stellt
russland dann in die energieversorgung
ein und all das könnte natürlich zu
einer weiteren es nation führen hennig
blickst du da drauf ist a dieser war
diese sorge berechtigt und b wie hat man
das jetzt gelöst
na ja es ist tatsächlich so dass wenn
hilft abgestellt wird für die russen und
machen das so zu formulieren es
schwierig ist die energierechnung zu
bezahlen schwierig nicht unmöglich wie
schon gesagt das geht auch perfekt weil
das nicht so komplexe geschäfte sind
aber es ist schwierig darüber hinaus
davon auch nicht vergessen wird das team
der der russischen schulden schwierig
das können zu ausfällen führen im westen
und mit den russischen banken
kooperieren natürlich auch europäische
bahnen und ein russischer banken in
schieflage geraten wegen eines hilft
ausschlusses hat das auch folgen für
europäische banken und aus diesen drei
gründen gab es nicht nur in deutschland
sondern auch allen voran italien
ziemlichen widerstand zunächst gegen
diese schrift ausschluss und man muss am
ende aussagen so wie er jetzt
stattfindet ist es ja auch einen
teilausschluss man hat sich darauf
geeinigt wie
der des geschäfts damit zu treffen aber
sowohl die gazprombank tiefe die
abwicklung der gast wichtig ist dass die
sberbank die größte russische bank als
ich ehrlich bislang hängt auch mittels
rückwirkungen die ein zusammenbruch
dieser bank für europäische dann haben
könnte es ist also in dem sinne auch
dann von europäischer seite abgespeckt
das rift aus kurz am ende praktisch
geschlossen worden
ja der luxemburgische außenminister jean
asselborn hatte ja gesagt wir wollen
nicht auch noch eine welthandels krise
provozieren das ist natürlich richtig
aber wie schätzt so dass ein ist das
jetzt ein so eine halbherzige
geschichte die die russen eigentlich gar
nicht soweit trifft wenn die jeden tag
noch 600 millionen dollar von uns also
dem westen bekommen
und die die währungsreserven praktisch
einfriert von von europäisch genau das
ist der zweite große punkt genau das
greift dann würde sagen zusammen weil
wenn die russen jetzt zum beispiel jeden
tag 600 millionen dollar bekommen für
energielieferung im anschluss aber mit
diesen dollar nichts mehr anfangen
können weil sie gar nicht konvertieren
können großartig wäre tut es ihnen
natürlich schon wie also vor dem
hintergrund würde ich nicht sprechen
aber man hat auch sehr genau darauf
geachtet dass man sich nicht selbst zu
der wehtut ob das jetzt unter
politischen gesichtspunkten vielleicht
dann auch ein bisschen weniger ehrgeizig
ist als man sich wünschen würde die
frage kann man durchaus stellen da war
auch wichtig noch ein letzter punkt eine
kurze nachfrage zu dem thema swift da
gab es zwischenzeitlich auch mal das
gerücht dass auch die italiener eine
ausnahme haben wollten für ihre luxus
produkte also wahrscheinlich wein und
teures öl oder so dass sie nach russland
exportieren ich habe davon jetzt nichts
mehr gehört
haben sie das zurückgezogen diese
forderung nein das hat er letztlich mit
gar nicht so viel zu tun da geht es
letztlich um die
importe exporte nach russland nicht
weiter gedreht also durchaus nach wie
vor möglich für die italiener ihre
taschen und anderen luxusprodukte nach
russland zu verkaufen genau wie die
belgier richtig sei dass ihre diamanten
dannenberg nach wie vor verkaufen können
immer unter der prämisse natürlich dass
diese geschäftsbeziehung ablegt
abwicklung schwieriger werden dadurch
und das hat natürlich schon wieder auch
durchaus folgen auch die ausfuhr aber es
ist keine zb ausfuhrverbot für durch die
taschen oder luxus produkte verhängt
sondern nur dann die zahlung die
gegebenenfalls je nach bank schwieriger
wird kommen wir zu dem zweiten punkt du
hast ihn schon angesprochen die blockade
der reserven den russischen nationalbank
sachen uns doch mal was heißt es
eigentlich was sind diese reserven
und was passiert jetzt mit den oder was
kann man jetzt vielmehr nicht mehr mit
denen machen
eigentlich spannende an diesem paket ist
der fokus war sehr stark
darüber viel streit davor darf und dass
auch die linz die gerade diesen
ausschuss als auch symbolisch wichtig
gefordert hat aber das eigentliche
vereine paketes ist das einstellen oder
die blockade ausgehende wahrsten sinne
des wortes ist es nicht aber die
blockade der zentralbankreserven das
sind sozusagen die vorräte die
nationalbank angehäuft hat in dollar
euro in gold auch wenn also der
chinesischen währung nicht nur westliche
währung und die man sozusagen in der
hinterhand hat um den rubel zu stützen
falls es zu kursschwankungen kommt da
nicht ganz unwichtig in dem zusammenhang
aber auch schlicht und einfach natürlich
nutzen kann und dann auch
entsprechend mit diesen währungen
einkaufen zu gehen und das ist etwas
anderes ob ich mit dollar einkaufen kann
oder mit dem rubel der im augenblick
werden nun auch gegen der umstände sehr
stark unter druck geht ist da reden wir
von insgesamt 630 milliarden schätzt im
wald ganz genau weiß man nicht und davon
ist großer teil gut 20 prozent 13 14
prozent chinesische währung aber der der
große rest sind lästige währungen in
ihren also japanische mittel und die
kann man zu einem großteil starren mehr
als die hälfte der gesamtsumme ist das
auf jeden fall und das tut den rücken
auch richtig das heißt das lied da das
geld ist natürlich nicht weg aber sie
können es schlicht nicht benutzen nicht
einsetzen weil wir das nicht akzeptieren
als wechsel sozusagen es liegt vor allen
dingen eben nicht nur darin jene von in
russland sondern es liegt eben nicht in
russland sondern außerhalb russlands
das ist nicht transparent also man
genau welche summe so liegt man kann das
aber nachvollziehen und so eine
partition l mehr mittel in amerika das
hat die russische lauf der letzten jahre
zurück gefahren aus naheliegenden
gründen könnte man heute sagen oder
konnte man auch da schon sagen es liegt
nach schätzung durchaus ein großer teil
auch in deutschland davon
und dieses ganze diese ganzen mit kann
man blockieren und dann könnten sie
nicht einsetzen um zb die folgen der
sanktion abzupuffern um den rubel zu
stützen und um dieses geld sozusagen zu
nutzen können das ist sozusagen die
vielleicht noch einmal für die menschen
richte mich dazu zähle die mit diesen
internationalen finanzströmen nicht so
ganz vertraut sind wie das funktioniert
also ich stelle mir jetzt vor der westen
überweist jeden tag 600 millionen dollar
für energie die wir aus russland
beziehen
und das ist ja geld das wir jetzt im
alten system trifft noch gegen einfach
schlicht dahin überweisen wahrscheinlich
jeden tag sondern gebündelt nehme ich an
dieses geld haben dann also ist dann
wechselt den eigentümer das heißt der
russische staat oder gastraum je nachdem
bekommt dieses geld und das liegt dann
wo und was passiert jetzt damit
zu sagen dann erstmals dollar bezahlt
und diese dollar die werden die
nationalbank
gespeist und im zweifel in ruggell
umgewandelt damit man dann im russland
damit entsprechen die da was kaufen
verkaufen geschäfte machen kann und
einfach auszudrücken und wiederum das
geld ist wiederum sozialgeld gesagt
dollar beträgt also die die
dollarscheine platz anzutreffen sind
natürlich keine steine im 1 die hätte
seine nationalbank zu ganz alten zeiten
zweifel vorgelegt und dann das geld
wieder rausgeholt auf der anderen seite
irgendwelche dinge sagen wir mal
luxusprodukt norditalien einkaufen heute
weil man da ja da nicht google bezahlen
können sollen dann bräuchte man euro
oder den usa eben dollar und da sollte
man sie dazu wieder benutzt und das
ganze ist natürlich heutzutage alles
nicht mehr im sinne von tresor
geldscheine oder auch goldbarren darum
gibt ja auch sondern also im zweifel
alles entsprechend virtuell kann
verschoben werden ist jetzt aber
größtenteils eben in den westen in den
ländern geparkt irgendwelchen konten und
würde in zeiten von russland genutzt
werden können um eben die ich die dinge
einkaufen müssen sagt eine gucci taschen
sein sondern können eben auch wichtige
produkte seien
die für den krieg oder etwas das
aufrechterhalten des russischen staates
wichtig sind und die können jetzt eben
nicht mehr bezahlt werden weil die
russen wie soll ein nicht mehr her
googeln kommen können und mit kugeln
können wir nicht kaufen weil sie keiner
haben und das geld kann jetzt eben nicht
mehr so ohne weiteres umgewandelt werden
wenn ich das genau verstanden habe gut
dann haben wir das geklärt vielen dank
ergeht nun dazu passt auch das zitat von
ursula von der leyen der
kommissionspräsident in die gesagt hat
damit werden wir putin daran hindern
seine kriegskasse zu nutzen also diese
rund 600 milliarden euro die da liegen
kann er eben dann auch nicht mehr
einsetzen um neues gerät zu beschaffen
waffen munition und anderes ok kommen
wir zum dritten punkt der betrifft die
oligarchen die ja auch sehr sehr viel
geld haben und natürlich auch
putin und der kriegskasse sagen wir mal
zur hilfe eilen könnten da soll das
vermögen jetzt eingefroren worden seien
wo liegt denn deren geld und wie
gestaltet sich das wo deren geld ganz
genau liegt weiß man natürlich dann auch
sich aber in der schweiz auch in anderen
mitgliedstaaten frankreich auf deutschen
konten das geht ja auch darum wieder die
sie zieren oder es genau liegt und eben
auch dann dazu zu sorgen dass sie darauf
keinen zugriff haben und auch daher
greift alles ineinander
geht es tatsächlich darum das nicht wenn
der russische staat keine sachen
einkaufen kann wie er braucht nicht
statt des theologischen losgehen auch
vermeintlich private kasse machen
deswegen ist wichtig in angriff mit
allen parteien sprechen auch
einzugreifen oder sicherzustellen dass
das unmöglich
okay dann ist auch noch die rede dass
der verkauf von eu pässen an oligarchen
so habe ich das verstanden unterbunden
werden soll wie stelle ich mir das vor
die kaufen in größerem stil erkaufen
sich die eine europäische also eine
staatsangehörigkeit europas oder wie was
ist das natürlich genauso das ist schon
sehr lange in der kritik das ziel auch
oder sehr stark aber wahrlich muss nur
auf zypern bei der wo es seit jahren
schon ein regelrechtes geschäfte mit
illegalen oder generell nicht nur
russische oligarchen auch aus anderen
staaten wo man vielleicht kritisch sein
könnte durch bestimmte investitionen die
im land tätigen sich gleichzeitig auch
ein pass des landes verkaufen und mit
diesem preis sind natürlich dann
eu-bürger und können entsprechend auch
als die bürger aktiv werden und dann
kann man ihn auch nicht ohne weiteres
mehr konten sperren oder andere
attraktionen auf erledigen damit das ist
die gleichen anspruch haben auf alle
gleich behandelt werden müssen du und
ich und vor dem hintergrund ist das
natürlich auch noch bei den punkt der
konfliktsituation
so und dann gibt es noch das
einreiseverbot wo er hat glaube ich
zunächst
putin ausgenommen war sondern das betraf
sein enges umfeld und dann sind aber
auch putin und der russische
verteidigungsminister auf diese liste
gekommen was dürfen die jetzt alles
nicht als sie dürfen nicht hier
einreisen und gibt es noch weitere
beschränkungen
sie dürfen mich ein
[Musik]
eigentlich so behandelt wie die
oligarchen die bisher auch schon
betroffen waren und könne neben darüber
hinaus gibt es keine sonderbehandlung
und noch eine letzte frage zur
einordnung dieses sehr umfassenden
pakets also erstmal würdest du sagen das
ist das umfassendste das es je gab gegen
ein land von seiten der eu
die frage schnell beantwortet hat auf
jeden fall
war
das längst nicht so hart war wie man
vorher den menschen die menschen hat
glauben machen wollen aber das war jetzt
geschlossen ist hat eine enorme wucht in
die wolken wird man noch nicht ganz
abdrehen können ist jetzt die russen
enorm unter druck ob es so weit geht
dass man sie damit in die knie zwingen
kann ist eine andere frage weil man erst
unter den iran gesehen hat und die
sanktionen gegen den iran
teilweise dann doch herr kam noch dass
das mit so können widerspreche ich mir
gerade vielleicht ein bisschen aber der
iran hat trotz aller schwierigkeiten
er hat immer noch das regime hat sich
immer noch an der macht halten können
vor dem hintergrund immer noch mal
schauen wie am ende sich die dinge
entwickeln aber in einer relativ
scharfes schwert da schon genau da hast
du für sie die frage die ich noch nicht
gestellt habe beantwortet aber ich frag
trotzdem nochmal nach die eben die frage
ist wie wie wirkt das und was von diesen
dingen am anfang ist es ja bei den
ersten zwei paketen das habe putin alles
einkalkuliert davon sei sozusagen klar
ausgegangen dass das kommt und das nehme
er deshalb in kauf jetzt hört man ja
dass die sanktionen doch umfassender
sind als er sich das wohl gedacht hat
wobei niemand natürlich weiß was in
seinem kopf vorgeht und dass man jetzt
ja auch erster bericht gehört dass es
offenbar von seiten der oligarchen die
das alles natürlich auch nicht so witzig
finden dass sie auf ihr vieles geld
nicht mehr zugreifen können dass sie so
eingeschränkt sind in vielen anderen
punkten dass die anfang druck zu machen
was ihn auch was natürlich für putin
auch unangenehm ist wenn er sorge haben
muss dass die vielleicht ihn von der
fahne gehen ich weiß nicht wie
realistisch das ist es ist
wahrscheinlich auch insgesamt sehr sehr
schwer einzuschätzen er hat von
außerhalb aber wie schätzt du dass ein
also hat russland diese sanktion nicht
so befürchtet was glaubt man da in
brüssel und ja damit verbunden wie
könnte sich das auswirken
also die frage ist schon richtig
formuliert was glaubt man einem boxer
der weiß glaube ich der eindruck
verfestigt sich
das
paket beschlossen worden das ist mit dem
putin leben hätte können und dass dieses
dritte paket doch dann über der pax doch
der schritt mehr ist den er glaube ich
nicht erwartet hatte am ende weiß
niemand ist auch schwer zu sagen
das beeindrucken wird viele der
beschlüsse werden sich sozusagen auch er
im laufe der nächsten tage dann wird
wirkung zeigen und in den duden
niederschlagen soll heißen ich voll und
bucht hat das ganze auch noch nicht
entfaltet
was am ende die konsequenz sein wird
wird man sehen wenn man den iran als
vergleich heran da muss man sagen hat
die wirtschaft brutal gelitten dass
einbrüchen 8 prozent des
wirtschaftswachstums gehen das ist sehr
sehr sehr sehr viel aber der iran das
regime hat sich halten können vor dem
hintergrund muss man auch konstatieren
man kann putin man kann russland mit
diesem gang schon sehr sehr weh tun zum
fall bringen allein wird man damit nicht
das sagen ja auch andere analysten dass
insgesamt wirtschaftssanktionen
weltweit gesehen historisch gesehen
selten richtig viel bewirkt haben selten
jemanden wirklich in die knie gezwungen
haben sondern natürlich auch du hast das
gesagt uns treffen auch natürlich dort
die zivilgesellschaft treffen
das heißt die frage bleibt natürlich das
was ein echter game changer wäre wäre
ein engagement in militärisches
engagement wenn ich nur waffenlieferung
über die wir schon gesprochen haben
sondern auch letztlich der einsatz der
nato und der ist soweit ich das von hier
aus berlin beobachtet überhaupt kein
thema sondern das wird nach wie vor
trotz der luftschläge der russen
kategorisch ausgeschlossen oder henrik
jetzt wirklich die letzte frage ist das
gibt es da bei der nato irgend ein
umdenken von dem wir hier noch nichts
mitbekommen haben
nicht dass sie sich irgendwie man
abgerechnet ich glaube diesen schritt
kann man und da würde ich noch nicht mal
nur im augenblick sagen den kann man
ausschließen dadurch die schulden noch
sehr sehr viel passieren ich möchte nur
einen punkt dann doch mal zu der
wirtschaft angezogen sagen das kann
jetzt alle sehr sehr negativ formuliert
da wurde der defensiv wollte ich
eigentlich sagen ganz so wenig biss hat
das was geschlossen worden ist
verglichen auch mit traditionellen
wirtschaftssanktionen von denen dann oft
die rede ist doch nicht und man könnte
natürlich schon etwas tun nämlich
schlicht und einfach von europäischer
seite sagen wir kaufen keine kohle öl
und kein gas mehr das wäre radikal das
hätte fatale auswirkungen natürlich auch
für die eu wäre zu verkraften aber das
wäre noch mal eine schippe drauflegen
könnte nun die durchaus noch einiges
ändern das ist ja auch eine diskussion
hier in berlin auch wirtschaftsminister
robert habeck hat sich ja mehrfach dazu
geäußert dass es aber so aus deutscher
sicht selbst aus grüner sicht eben noch
in relativ weiter ferne hat heute morgen
im deutschlandfunk noch mal gesagt dass
wir derzeit eben noch davon abhängig
sind und das alles andere noch etwas
länger dauert wenn das wirklich wenn das
auch von seiten russlands abgestellt
werden würde würde das natürlich
tatsächlich bedeuten wir müssen hier den
gürtel deutlich enger schnallen und nur
noch die hälfte unseres energiebedarfs
ja unseren energiebedarf wirklich massiv
drosseln was tatsächlich weh tun würde
es wäre sicherlich der wahrscheinlich
entschieden und radikale schritt und an
der der russland am allermeisten weh tut
und das ist dann am ende die ganze frage
der solidarität
das ist immer schnell gesagt und dann am
ende zeigt es sich natürlich nur dadurch
wenn man selber auch bereit ist echte
einschnitte in kauf zu nehmen das ist
alles
zukunftsmusik
hendrik ich danke dir ich danke dir
übrigens auch für die klarstellung mit
der oder dein einwand mit der
finanziellen atombombe in der tat in
diesen zeiten wo die echte atombombe
droht und zumindest wieder zumindest
angedroht wird sollte man das nicht
sagen es war nur ein zitat aber richtig
dass an dieser stelle nicht zu benutzen
so und ein paar stunden nach dem
gespräch mit hendrik kafsack gab es noch
ein update deshalb haben wir uns noch
einmal zusammen geschaltet hendrik die
ereignisse überschlagen sich ja sowieso
seit tagen was hat sich nun in brüssel
verändert bleibt die kapelle aufgestellt
wird die hauptwirkung ist auch noch mal
geringer als ursprünglich erwartet nicht
mal irgendwann aber gerade was ziemlich
20 prozent des bankgeschäfts gestalten
statt der dies ja davor noch 70 gruppen
das hängt verein offensichtlich damit
begonnen dass man sich alle kanäle
offenheit zu zahlen von
energierechnungen von staatsschulden
aber eben auch hinderte das folgen für
die weltwirtschaft hat und da haben
offensichtlich sogar die amerikaner auch
eine rolle gespielt diana interveniert
haben und auch betrogen haben das ganze
doch nicht zu ärgerlich ausfällt würde
wir hatten ja vorhin schon einen sagen
ich mal vorsichtige ja ein bisschen die
frage wie wirkungsvoll ist das jetzt
alles jetzt nochmal das fazit
ändert sich jetzt was an seiner
bewertung dieses ganzen pakets
naja in bürglen das ist wahrscheinlich
noch mal mit ein vorsichtiger formuliert
werden die ganze frucht die schrift
ausschluss betrifft im galli galli
potenten 70 hotels in die seite den
roten wirklich weh tut muss man fördern
in ruhe anschauen ich ging natürlich
auch die möglichkeit dann jetzt geschäft
über andere banken die nicht betroffen
sind zu schleusen und damit die regeln
ausschuss hatte ich dazu geben nicht
verändert sich natürlich an der wucht
trifft die man mit blick auf die
notenbank beschlossen hat aber zeigt
dann hat mich schwer es dann doch soll
die sanktionen verhängt worden als ich
selbst tun genau das ist ja die vorgabe
gewesen auch aus deutschland möglichst
die russen treffen und uns selber nicht
ja also vielen dank nochmal für das
update wir versuchen ja immer in diesen
bewegten zeiten so aktuell wie möglich
zu sein und das erfordert eben auch den
ein oder anderen schnitt in so einem
podcast also vielen dank noch mal an
dich hendrik wunderbar
[Musik]
jetzt kommen wir zum einzigen teil
dieser sendung der sich nicht mit der
lage in der ukraine
befasst nämlich unserem gerechten urteil
und spoiler es geht auch nicht um corona
es geht nicht um cola es geht nicht um
die ukraine aber es geht um etwas was
auch für sehr viel empörung sorgte
nämlich um autorennen und die frage wie
man dem
strafrechtlich herr werden kann
wir erinnern uns im jahr 2016 war das
schon mal ein riesenthema weil
insbesondere hier in berlin wir ja immer
wieder ganz
wahnsinnig gefährliche autorin hatten
unter anderem auf unserer edel meile
die auch also weit über berlin hinaus
für schlagzeilen sorgen weil es da sehr
sehr tragische
unfälle gab es hat da zu einem wandel in
der rechtsprechung und auch in der
gesetzgebung geführt also man hat schon
gesehen dass das überhand nimmt das auch
die deutsche das deutsche recht dem
wenig entgegensetzen kann der boden
wahnsinnig gefährliche rennen
veranstaltet und dann kann man quasi mit
dem eine ordnungswidrigkeit raus wenn
nicht viel passiert ist ja also wenn es
gut gelaufen ist und da hat man an
verschiedenen
stellschrauben gedreht ich möchte jetzt
nicht alle sozusagen
aufwärmen weil wir ja wir haben hier
schon drüber gesprochen darüber
inwieweit das auch ein mord sein kann
wenn dabei jemand ums leben kommt darum
geht es nicht sondern es geht um einen
paragrafen 315 de der im zuge dessen
eingeführt wurde der
2017 dann in kraft getreten ist wo es
darum ging illegale autorennen unter
strafe zu stellen und eben nicht nur
rennen sondern es gibt ja die nummer
drei im man eben nicht mit jemandem
anders sondern quasi gegen sich selber
rennt so stelle ich mir das jedenfalls
vor diesmal die vorschrift oder steht
wer im straßenverkehr nummer drei sich
als kraftfahrzeugführer mit nicht
angepasster geschwindigkeit und grob
verkehrswidrig und rücksichtslos
fortbewegt um eine höchstmögliche
geschwindigkeit zu erreichen wird mit
freiheitsstrafe bis zu zwei jahren
bestraft oder mit geldstrafe bestraft
also mit nicht angepasster
geschwindigkeit grob verkehrswidrig und
rücksichtslos um eine höchstmögliche
geschwindigkeit zu erreichen da hast du
schon das problem wunderbar aufbereitet
das sind natürlich alles wachsweiche
formulierungen
und das sorgte eben in der
rechtsprechung und in der literatur sehr
dafür für eine große diskussionen
darüber ob das ganze denn überhaupt dem
bestimmtheitsgebot des grundgesetzes
genügte also ob einem norm wie du sie
jetzt eben gerade vorgelesen hast so
klar ist dass sich auch jeder daran
halten kann das ist ja sinn und zweck
also ich muss einfach mit anderen worten
alleine sehr sehr schnell fahren dann
könnte es schon sein dass ich in diese
ja und da gab es eben schon auf den
unteren instanzen also unterhalb des
bundesverfassungsgerichts
unterschiedliche auslegungen da war eben
zum beispiel dann die frage na also
musst du tatsächlich die möglichkeiten
des jeweiligen autors
ausreizen ja wir haben letztens den fall
des bugatti besprochen der über mit über
400 über die straßen über die autos über
die autobahn
donnert ist ja das ist also ein bugatti
kann bringen natürlich mehr auf die
straße als
klappriger golf also wie ist sozusagen
sind diese einzelnen dinge zu bewerten
inwieweit ist auch in diesem
zusammenhang notwendig dass es so eine
art von rennen gibt also all das wurde
diskutiert das landgericht startet zb
hatte dafür einen renn ähnlichen
charakter verlangt ja
der erfüllt ist wenn der fahrer sein
fahrzeug an die technischen und
physikalischen grenzen auswärts so so
und jetzt hatte sich das
bundesverfassungsgericht damit zu
beschäftigen weil ein amtsgericht ein
fall vorgelegt hat wo das mal geprüft
werden sollte da kann man schon sehen
der amtsrichter das passiert jetzt auch
nicht so wahnsinnig häufig dass ein
amtsrichter eine norm vorlegt und die
verfassungsrichter in karlsruhe um eine
einschätzung bitte er muss ja nicht
vorlegen der darf nur genau er darf und
er war offensichtlich dann doch so
empört über das was der gesetzgeber da
abgeliefert hatte dass er das vorgelegt
hat wir können vielleicht noch mal sagen
worum es ging also da ist eben ein mann
auf der flucht vor der polizei in der
geschlossenen ortschaft zwischen 80 und
100 stundenkilometern gefahren also man
sieht schon das ist schon verdammt
schnell und verdammt gefährlich aber es
geht natürlich noch mehr ja- und sein
verteidiger hat eben auch genau das
angeführt und argumentieren eine
strafbarkeit wegen paragraf 315 de komme
nicht in frage da das fluchtfahrzeug
weit höhere geschwindigkeiten hätte
erreichen können aber er ist auch noch
über rote ampeln getan oder ja ja es
stimmt also das ist natürlich auch noch
wichtig zu wissen es ist keine
schnurgerade sie auch seltenen
geschlossenen ortschaften dass man sich
frei bewegen also ein grob
verkehrswidrig ist wahrscheinlich die
rote ampel also wenn du subsumiert genau
und hier musste war eben die frage
können auch quasi autofahrer nur wie du
es formuliert hass gegen sich selbst ein
rennen fahren wobei sie er war auf der
flucht vor der polizei also wenn es so
argumentieren möchte das kann es auch
sagen er hat sich quasi mit der polizei
ein rennen geliefert die hatten
schwierigkeiten ihm zu folgen und hätten
ihn auch fast aus den augen verloren das
war also die konstellation die dann vor
dem bundesverfassungsgericht
gelandet ist und was hat karlburg ii
haben die die norm durchgewinkt und
haben gesagt das ist bestimmt genug das
ist klar genug man kann natürlich jetzt
kommt nicht daran vorbei dass ein paar
dinge auslegungsbedürftig sind aber die
sagen ihm dass wie hier der
bundesgerichtshof schon in vielen
verfahren in vielen urteilen dafür ein
gewisses stringenz und
marschrichtung gesorgt hat also dass
das haben sie angeführt und das zweite
war eben das auch die gesetzesbegründung
herangezogen werden könne um so was wie
grob verkehrswidrig rücksichtslos oder
auch das fahren mit nicht angepasster
geschwindigkeit für den fall zu
definieren und hier gilt eben bei den
voraussetzungen dieser norm dass sie
nicht im engeren sinne bestimmt sein
müssen sondern dass es ausreicht wenn
sie bestimmbar sind also du hast das
gesagt ein wenig nicht durch die
gesetzesbegründung oder durch
rechtsprechung wo bestimmte begriffe
eben klar definiert sind und dass es bei
den begriffen so jedenfalls karlsruhe
der fall und da kann man eben einfach
noch mal sehen das begehren der wunsch
von karlsruhe vielleicht dem gesetzgeber
da nicht so allzu sehr an den karren
fahren ist jetzt vielleicht auch ein
falsches bild aber sie wissen was ich
meine also jedenfalls sich zu sehr
ins werk zu folgen so eine norm kann
natürlich auch nicht zu eng formuliert
sein fett dann letztendlich gar keinen
fall darunter hat ja auch niemand was
davon und wir finden dass jetzt gerächt
weil wir gegen rasen sind wir sind gegen
raase ich möchte vielleicht das noch ein
bisschen einschränken ich würde
vielleicht sagen ich kann schon
verstehen um vielleicht auch mal die
kritiker abzuholen und auch den
amtsrichter der da vorgelegt hat ich
kann schon verstehen dass man da
irgendwie seine bedenken hat bei dieser
norm und dass sich klarer gewünscht
hätte auf der anderen seite finde ich
ist das jetzt eine entscheidung die sich
hören lässt und es ist jetzt gut dass
rechtssicherheit da ist weil das ist ja
auch etwas was jetzt schon seit vier
jahren wird und was immer wieder auch an
unterschiedlichen gerichten für ärger
gesorgt hat das wird jetzt die
rechtsprechung natürlich noch weiter
beschäftigen wir müssen natürlich in
jedem einzelfall schauen und die sachen
aus legen und sich da vielleicht beim
bundesgerichtshof und seinen
einschätzungen bedient aber das ist eben
auch rechtsprechung so ist es und
deswegen finden wir es nicht nur
gerecht weil wirklich raser auf der
autobahn aber auch in ortschaften echt
furchtbar sind gerade wenn man wie ich
meistens fahrrad fährt aber auch weil es
heißt es so schön gesagt für die
rechtssicherheit und damit für den
rechtsfrieden
von vorteil ist und frieden ist ja in
diesen tagen ein gut dass man erst so
richtig zu schätzen weiß wenn auch
dieser vergleich hinkt ich gebe es zu ja
da kann man so stehen wir können mal
genau insofern mit dem mit der hoffnung
auf frieden auch diesen podcast beenden
und danken sehr herzlich für die
aufmerksamkeit für diese zweihundertste
folge heute am mittwoch den 2 märz 2022
es wird hoffentlich auch bald frühling
ja herzlichen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit sagt auch ich bleiben sie
gesund und schreiben sie gerne wieder
rein und machen sie vor einigen mit bei
unserer umfrage das würde uns wahnsinnig
weiterhelfen und schließlich ihn aber ab
aber ab und machen sie gerne kommentare
kritik jegliche hinweise und anmerkung
und hörer wünsche die wir dann gerne in
der nächsten folge aufnehmen
[Musik]